حسنًا ، عاد بعض المتسوقين بالفعل إلى
دبي مع فتح أحد أكبر
مراكز التسوق في العالم أبوابه مرة أخرى ، لكن
الحشود كانت قليلة بعد
إغلاق دام شهرًا ، يعاد افتتاح المركز التجاري
بسعة 30 بالمائة ليبدأ بشكل طبيعي
250 ألف شخص يوميًا يزورون
المركز  ما مجموعه 83 مليون في العام الماضي
يضم المركز التجاري 1300 متجرًا للبيع بالتجزئة و
200 منفذًا للطعام ، كما أن تراس John Dave الخاص بشبكة CNN
موجود في هذا المركز التجاري في
دبي وينضم إلينا الآن من الجيد رؤيتك يا جون ،
فما هي الاحتياطات التي يتخذونها
لضمان سلامة المتسوقين؟  وهل هناك عدد
كافٍ من العملاء الذين يخرجون بشكل جيد ،
فلدينا الكثير من إكليل الجبل بالفعل
وهو هادئ بشكل مخيف هنا
لأنه قبل نصف ساعة من الافتتاح الرسمي
ولكن هذا جزء من الرسالة
هنا إعادة إطلاق بسيطة إذا كنت ستفعل ذلك مع
الإجراءات الأمنية في  المكان
وخلال هذه الفترة الهادئة قبل
الافتتاح في منتصف النهار ودبي دعونا
نحضر رئيس مجلس الإدارة فهو الرجل الذي
حلم بالفكرة طورها
وسلمها إنها محمد.  د العبار
رئيس عمار سعيد أن أراك ترى ما هي
الرسالة هنا هذا مثير للاهتمام لأنك
أتيت في الأسبوعين الأولين من
رمضان والتي لاحظت أنها فترة أبطأ
ولكن الرسالة إلى العالم الخارجي
هي أننا  إعادة التشغيل ولكننا لسنا
عدوانيين بشكل مفرط ، فنحن نحاول
أن نقول إنك تعلم أن هناك الكثير
الذي تم إنجازه وفي المدينة قامت
الحكومة بعمل رائع ولكن
إذا كان إغلاق المدينة
وشروط الاختبار ،  أنت تعلم اليوم أننا
ربما نكون أعلى نصيب للفرد عندما
يتعلق الأمر بالاختبار في العالم ،
يلتزم الجميع بالقواعد واللوائح
الجديدة وأعتقد أن الأهم من ذلك هو أنني أعتقد
أيضًا أن الحكومة ساعدت
المجتمع على تعلم المعايير الجديدة ، وبالتالي
بعد أكثر من شهر  من الإغلاق ،
أعتقد أيضًا أن الحكومة تريد منا
محاولة العودة ومحاولة العودة
بعناية تدريجيًا ، وأنا أحب هذه
الفكرة خاصةً أنه يتزامن مع
الأسبوعين الأولين من رمضان حيث يكون
هذا هو أبطأ وقت
إذا كان هذان الأسبوعان أبطأ في العام ،
فامنحهم بائع تجزئة أي موظف
ليعود إليه أولاً حتى نحاول
، وعلى الرغم من أننا فعلنا ذلك ،
فقد فعلنا كل الأشياء التي نحتاج
إلى القيام بها للحماية  الجميع ولكن أعتقد
أنها محاولة جيدة ومن الجيد
الخروج وتجربتها وأن تكون
قادرًا على ضبطها وتعديلها عندما نبدأ
في هذه الفترة الزمنية البطيئة ولكنك
تتحدث عن فترة بطيئة
يقترح صندوق النقد الدولي
أن المنطقة ستشهد
ركوداً بنسبة 3٪ وربما أعلى
هنا في الإمارات. كيف تخطط لمثل
هذا الاضطراب الجذري ، فهذه ليست
الحرب الإيرانية العراقية ، بل حرب الخليج ، التي
استفاد منها الربيع العربي دبي.
ملاذ آمن ، هذا حقًا خارج الصندوق
بالطبع تعلم أنك تعرف هل سيكون جون
دبي مركزًا تجاريًا ونحن
نعتمد حقًا على الشركات من آسيا وروسيا ،
ولا توجد حواجز حولك في المملكة العربية السعودية
لأنك حصلت على إفريقيا أيضًا  على
الجانب الآخر آسف لمزيج
الأعمال التي  لدينا أشخاص يجب أن
ينظروا إلينا حقًا لأن تركيزنا بشكل أساسي
حقًا على النفط على
النفط ودخل النفط وتأثير دخل النفط
بالإضافة إلى الدخل الكبير الذي نحصل
عليه والمساهمة من السياحة التي
ستتأثر أيضًا  بعض الوقت
لكني أعتقد أنك تعلم أن المدن العالمية
بشكل عام ستخوض هذا
التغيير الجديد والتعديل ، فبعض المدن سوف
تتكيف بشكل أفضل من غيرها ، وأعتقد حقًا
أنه مع حجم المدينة
وسياسة الحكومة وعدم
الاعتماد على  النفط أعتقد أن فرصة عودة
هذه المدينة إلى الوراء ستعود
، أعتقد أن الذهاب إلى الامتحان
حتى نعود جميعًا ، لكنني أعتقد أنه سيكون في
وضع أفضل إذا تحدثت عن العودة ،
فهل يستغرق الأمر عامًا للتعافي؟
ترى شكل v تقوم بجمع البيانات من
أعمالك عبر الإنترنت مثل نون ولديك
جميع أنواع البيانات الواردة من دبي
مول هنا كم من الوقت يستغرق
التعافي لا أرى شكل v في الواقع
أنا واحد  من المحافظين الذين
ينظرون إلى ر  أنا وأعتقد حقًا
أنه لكي يعود الإنسان إلى
حياته ، فأنت تنتظر اللقاح ، إنها
حقيقة من حقائق الحياة.أعتقد أن الأشخاص
وما نقوم به من وظائف
نحاول حقًا إخبار الناس أنه
لا يمكننا فقط أن نخاف و  اجلس في
منازلنا ،
لقد علمنا أن الحكومة قامت
بعمل رائع ، والآن دعونا نجرب هذا
الشيء
، لنجرب هذا الشيء بعناية وهذا
الفحص ، لنكن سارة مثالًا
جيدًا للعالم أيضًا ، لذا أتوقع أنه يتعين
علينا فعلاً أن نذهب تدريجياً  التحرك
صعودًا في نهاية العام إذا
لم يكن هناك تفشي كبير هناك ومن
ثم ربما إلى الربع الأول في
الجزء الأول والذي يتجاوز عندما
تبدأ في التعافي ثم في منتصف العام المقبل ،
ربما نحن طبيب رائع ، هذه فترة طويلة
من الزمن نهائي  سؤال لك
هناك مخاوف هنا من أن
الألعاب الأولمبية الصيفية في طوكيو لن تحدث
إذا كان الوباء لا يزال على قيد الحياة وكان من
المفترض أن يتبعه في أكتوبر
2021 هو معرض دبي إكسبو ما رأيك
أنه يمكن ذلك؟  كن ولادة جديدة ، وبطريقة
أو بأخرى ، عليك المضي قدمًا في
المعرض هذه المرة لأنه
تأخر لمدة عام جيدًا ، أعتقد أنه
الوقت المثالي للنظر في المواد التي
تقرأها وأقرأها ويقرأ الجميع عن
المكان الذي يأخذنا إليه هذا  أعتقد أنني متأكد
بنسبة مائة بالمائة من أن اللقاح
سيكون معنا حتى يعود إلى
شهر مارس من العام المقبل ، وأعتقد أنه
بحلول شهر أكتوبر ، يجب أن نكون جميعًا على ما يرام
لاستخدام إكسبو كوقت
للاحتفال وتوحيد العالم بعد ذلك.
أوقات مروعة